[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live
on attend vos points de vue l'émission
est un peu spéciale ce soir à des
entièrement consacré au premier
anniversaire du premier confinement
qu'est ce qui a vraiment changé bien on
va se poser la question vous allez nous
donner vos points de vue vos réponses
est-ce qu emmanuel macron a perdu la
guerre 1 celle de vivre au maximum sans
confinement et avec le virus
alors pendant débattre avec vous on a ce
soir pascal perrineau bonsoir pass'open
politologue professeur à sciences po et
auteur dernièrement de ce que sais-je
sur le populisme auteur entre autres
mais c'est ce qu'on recommande c'est le
sait le dernier-né tout à fait et avec
vous avec nous comme chaque mardi avec
six vases et bonsoir les consommations
avec si le figaro est revenu sur toutes
les questions autour d'astrazeneca ces
dernières heures on y revient encore je
ne la crains qu'on soit contraint d'y
revenir après demain et astra zeneca le
confinement leur confinement
les vaccins et c est comme si les choses
n'avaient pas finalement tellement
changé depuis un an depuis cette
déclaration
j'ai décidé de renforcer encore les
mesures pour réduire nos déplacements et
nos contacts au strict nécessaire dès
demain midi et pour quinze jours au
moins nos déplacements seront très
fortement réduit cela signifie que les
regroupements extérieur les réunions
familiales ou amicales ne seront plus
permises se promener retrouver ses amis
dans le parc dans la rue ne sera plus
possible
nous sommes en guerre alors en ce moment
emmanuel macron rencontre de nouveau une
délégation du conseil scientifique que
va t'il décidé sans attendre en tout cas
le premier ministre lui a fait à
l'assemblée nationale cette déclaration
cet après midi effectivement comme vous
le savez mesdames et messieurs nous
sommes dans ce qui ressemble à une forme
de troisième vague caractérisée par des
variants
nombreux qui s'est en tout cas le cas du
variant dit britannique prend une place
de plus en plus importante
alors une place de plus en plus
importante en france
alors le président lui va-t-il accepter
l'idée d'un confinement tout l'été en
ile-de-france dutil le faire je vous
propose avant d'en débattre d' écouter
la réponse de ces deux chefs de service
régulièrement invitée sur les plateaux
le confinement en fait c'est super je
pense que c'est la pire des c'est la
pire des solutions
clairement surtout d'un point de vue
mental d'un produit social d'un point de
vue économique je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord là dessus
après la actuellement on est confronté à
une saturation des unités
d'hospitalisation et surtout des unités
de réanimation et donc ça sert ainsi
viennent
oui francilienne ah oui je parle pas
d'un piège nationale évidemment je pense
que maintenant on est passé à une
régionalisation de la branche de
l'épidémie est bienvenu on on en avait
déjà parlé
donc oui je pense que c'est la
saturation du système de santé c'est la
saturation des animations qui pose le
problème parce que si par exemple vous
et vos proches est malade bad man lui
trouvera pas de place en réanimation
parce que les réanimations franc plein
de qu'ovide donc c'est ça le problème
et je pense qu'effectivement on ne peut
pas se passer on ne peut pas se passer d
excuser moi d'un confinement qui sont un
confinement comme la première vague
je ne sais pas s'il faut qu'il soit
national ça serait probablement injuste
mais un confinement régional qui laisse
les gens faire des migrations vers les
autres régions il un vrai problème avec
l'histoire des variants c'est qu'on peut
pas imaginer que par exemple on puisse
aller se balader avec les rats riant
dans d'autres régions qui sont pas
touchés et inversement
donc ça c'est un vrai pro lyon qu'il va
vous un confinement régional strictes
c'est à dire qu'on ne sort pas du
périmètre de la région exactement
ah et si les animations sont son plein
en ile-de-france et en taille dans la
stratégie vaccinale cet après midi
encore le gouvernement donc annoncé la
suspension du vaccin astrazeneca au
moins jusqu'à jeudi en attendant l'avis
de l'union européenne ce qui est manuel
macron peut dans ces conditions tenir
son pari de vivre avec le virus de
repousser un confinement en tout cas en
ile de france première région française
c'est sûr que la coïncidence de ces deux
phénomènes que vous décrivez c'est à
dire qu'une une épidémie qui continue
peut-être en accélérant pas de façon
exponentielle on le voit bien depuis des
semaines c'est pas du tout exponentielle
c'est pas du tout ce que nous avait dit
de d'une explosion mais c'est vrai qu'à
force de monter doucement ça finit par
atteindre un niveau préoccupant c'est
sûr ça plus les le vaccination qui
marquait le pas qui n'avançait pas qui
ne marche pas il m'a nancy rajoute le
fait qu'un des vaccins est mise en cause
par les personnes mêmes qui sont censés
développer le principe de la vaccination
donc l'un dans l'autre ça devient
compliqué c'est vrai que la position des
miels macron qui après avoir été
longtemps pendant quasiment un an de
jusqu'au tout cas jusqu'au mois
d'octobre de s'aligner à peu près
systématiquement sur les clés des
recommandations des autorités de santé
aboud avant se dit mais maintenant il y
en a assez chaque fois on me dit que ça
va être l'apocalypse la musique donc
maintenant je vais prendre mon risque et
je vais essayer de tenir bon à partir de
ce nom si de telles catastrophes moment
du deuxième confinement qui ne sont pas
venus que il a est depuis quelques
semaines maintenant
il essayait il a essayé il a réussi et
je pense que là c'est un point sur
lequel il faut foule lui rendre hommage
il a réussi à tenir le coup à dire non
ne comprennent pas tout de suite je
c'est vrai que maintenant ça devient de
plus en plus compliqué de tenir sans
dire
que la pression monde que tous les
épidermes et locke de la terre montrent
que jean castex revient que vera revient
et donc je crains que le maquereau
d'autre choix que de nous remettre en
prison parce qu'elle est ce que est ce
qu on sait ce que souhaite l'opinion sur
cette question est quelle ligne surtout
l'exécutif peut enfin emmanuel macron
exactement peut tenir alors l'opinion
elle est toujours en faveur d'une
protection un l'opinion ne veut pas que
les politiques publiques dégarnissent
des protections que ce soit celle des
couvre-feux que ce soit celle d'un
confinement
1 vous avez une majorité faible mais une
majorité qui est en faveur en effet très
forte c'est quand même une interrogation
le fait que les français étaient
confrontés à autre chose et en
particulier avec le choix présidentiel
qui a été un choix courageux dans la
dernière période à changer le rapport de
force donc les français restent en
faveur d'une protection simplement ils
hésitent sur les modalités de la
protection est ce que la protection
actuelle de couvre-feu différenciée
selon les régions
suffit ou est-ce qu'il faut repasser
peut-être pas nationalement 1 mais au
moins régionalement et en faisant
respecter ni frontières régionales parce
que sinon en effet le le virus va se
balader
c'est ce que disait en effet le
professeur pialoux tout à l'heure donc
là vous avez une opinion qui qui est
enfin vers la protection mais qui
commence à être usé
moi ce qui me frappe quand vous regardez
toutes les enquêtes
il ya tous les signes d'une forme de
dépression chez les français on parle
beaucoup et à juste titre moi qui suis
professeur je le vois bien avec les
étudiants les étudiants un an de ce
régime
il commence vraiment les problèmes de
santé publique
un son réel par exemple dans la
population étudiante qui se sent isolé
qui ne sait plus à quoi ça sert qui est
enfermé dans des petites chambres
presque jour et nuit devant des écrans
anonymes ces redoutables mais là on le
sent au plan collectif
au plan collectif il ya un phénomène dû
ur et le fait que le sentiment qu'on ne
voit pas le tunnel parce que projetons
nous il ya un an mais qui aurait dit il
ya un an qu'on se retrouverait un an
après dans cette situation en raison de
personne à personne et sa collectivement
si vous voulez l'opinion française le
sens hélas je salue les internautes qui
eux sont toujours présents et en
particulier qui a été présent pendant le
le confinement chardons bleus notamment
qui revient sur astrazeneca on va
prendre votre votre votre intervention
mais babineau aux internautes habituel
est habitué de point de vue on sent tout
de même un changement de ton au sein du
gouvernement et la ligne sanitaire
d'olivier verront reprend le pouvoir
est ce que c'est un sentiment je pouvoir
je sais pas mais en train est en train
de marquer des points
parce que il est vrai aussi que c'est
vrai que le l'épidémie progresse on nous
a dit c'est une course de vitesse il
faut vacciner et le discours de macron
s'entendait c'était de dire allez on
vaccine en vaccinant vaccine contient
quinze jours trois semaines
et puis va faire beau donc l'épidémie va
se ralentir et avec la vaccination va
emporter le boulot le truc le problème
c'est que on vaccine pas et il a tapé du
poing sur la table une fois deux fois
trois fois c'est très bien tapé du poing
sur la table mais la machine ne répond
pas la machine administrative
bureaucratique sanitaire n'a pas répondu
donc on vaccine pas et deux pendant ce
temps là c'est vrai que l'épidémie
s'arrête pas là reste que c'est le vario
anglais est ce que c'est pas leurs yeux
anglaise que c'est la course à peu près
naturel d'une épidémie on n'en sait rien
mais c'est vrai que dans notamment dans
les duels dans les urgences et la
réanimation il ya de plus en plus de
monde
après on peut aussi s'interroger c'est
quand on fait pendant un an pour
augmenter le nombre de livres et
réanimation rien c'est peut-être une
question qu'il faudra un jour se poser
comment un an
on a réussi ou échoué à créer le moindre
l'hydratation qu'on n'a même pas essayé
qu'on nous a dit on va vous vous êtes
bien c'est bien gentil ce pas vous vous
au sepa en trois mois en deux mois
conforme et réanimateurs ok c'est pas en
six mois qu'on formerait un étonnant
c'est pas un an conforme un radiateur
il faudra combien de temps pour former
rennais devra 10 ans 20 ans ça ne tient
pas debout
simplement qu'on a pas si rose on s'est
pas donné les moyens on aurait un peu
plus de lits de réanimation ont
mobiliserait un peu plus les lits de
réanimation du privé et il ya le on ne
fait parler par exemple le président de
syndicat d'aider les hôpitaux privés bon
bah je dis pas que ça permettrait de
résoudre tout mais ça permet de tenir un
peu plus longtemps
on a l'impression des faux-pas du début
ne cesse de se répéter et je crois que
ça participe beaucoup au sentiment
d'usure des français est il ils ont
l'impression parfois que les décideurs à
tort ou à raison n'ont pas appris de
leurs erreurs ou de leur faut pas passer
et ça c'est redoutable en termes de
perception il faut rajouter à cela le
choix qu'ils méritent même d'être
débattue d'avoir retiré
astrazeneca alors justement c'est la
question pas justement qu'on pose sur le
site du figaro et j'aimerais bien avoir
votre commentaire vos commentaires parce
que approuvez-vous le choix de suspendre
la vaccination par astrazeneca donc
avant le début de l'émission
on était quasiment 50 50 49 9% de oui 50
1 % 2
deux noms c'est à peu près la même chose
en ce moment il ya un petit peu plus de
votants vous pouvez continuer à voter
comment vous vous interprétez justement
se partagent deux lignes d eau
et question subsidiaire est ce que ce
qui condamne finalement cette suspension
comment vous interprétez est ce que
c'est un nom au confinement et comment
vous interpréter ça alors ce 50 50 il se
comprend dans une opinion publique
française qui lorsqu'on la compare aux
autres opinions publiques en europe
était une opinion déjà assez sceptique
vis-à-vis de la vaccination en tant que
tel 1
on a toujours eu on est le pays dans
lequel là il ya une très forte minorité
de français qui sont rétifs au vaccin on
avait réussi aux alentours du mois
d'octobre de novembre décembre a changé
un peu ce rapport de force et améliorer
la majorité des français qui veulent se
faire vacciner alors le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que les rumeurs en
tous sens plus que les informations sur
le vaccin
astrazeneca ont fait revenir le
scepticisme au premier plan et on le
voit dans les réponses des internautes
du figaro 50 50
alors que le débat mérite d'être mené
tout même des gens tout à fait sérieux
disent au fond là le pouvoir politique a
suivi ce qu'il perçoit comme étant être
un courant majoritaire d'opinion et la
tendance de certains pays comme les pays
bas par exemple qui ont décidé de mettre
un petit aulas temporaire à la diffusion
d'astrazeneca mais aussi les mêmes
autorités scientifiques parfois vous
disent mais il puisque le bleu problème
c'est la thrombose oublier injection de
l'astra zeneca et beaucoup vous disent
mais le taux de thrombose pour 1000
habitants n'ayant pas reçu l'asra zeneca
et 1000 habitants les reçus c'est le
même donc où est le problème
voyez où est le problème si ce n'est à
nouveau
une méfiance presque atavique d'une
partie de français qui se dit oh là là
là ils prennent le fameux principe de
précaution qu'ils l'emportent mais mais
mais attention parce qu'on déséquilibre
toute la politique d'ailleurs qui avait
été prévu par le président c'est à dire
en effet de prendre un risque mais à
condition d' accélérer massivement les
les vaccinations
or là si on retire astrazeneca non
seulement déjà on était un rythme lent
mais voilà on va être un rythme super
lent qui devait représenter 30% des
doses d'ici d'ici fin avril le sentiment
qu'on a c'est que la france et l'europe
collectivement c'est en train de pousser
le le principe de précaution jusqu'à
l'absurde eux-mêmes jusqu'au délire
parce que si on regarde les chiffres les
chiffres de alors que la gsee de la
france présente avec astrazeneca on a
une thrombose multiples pour 450 4025 ça
fait 0 0 0 0 3 0 22%
c'est fou pour pfizer ya aussi trente et
une thrombose veineuse profonde pour
quatre millions cinq cent soixante six
mille c'est 0 0 0 0 68%
mais évidemment si on si on vaccine 4
millions de personnes
il ya forcément des gens qui ont des
thromboses et forcément des gens qui se
casse la jambe dans l'escalier dans 4
millions c'est obligé c'est pas dû aux
vaccins soient pas de sens donc
et pourquoi on fait ça et et moi je
pense qu'il ya une espèce de confusion
qui fait bondir de double sens sur cette
affaire de principe de précaution on dit
on prendra des précautions pour protéger
les gens il faut faire très attention
donc il vaut mieux me virer cohésion je
crains que les politiques en europe
prennent des précautions pour se
protéger eux et quel est le cas parce
que on a vu ça c'est la peur qui s'est
répandue de pays en pays l'autriche à
l'avancé puis le danemark puis puis
l'allemagne et alors là une heure après
l'allemagne souffre la france n'a pas
attendu une heure de plus ça franchement
on n'a pas n'a pas traîné et pourquoi ça
se répand parce que les dirigeants
politiques se disent s'il est établi que
j'ai su que j'ai eu connaissance du fait
que le vaccin pouvait être possible
socialement dangereux et commandant ne
serait ce qu'un jour ou deux jours
continus et d'administrer ce vaccin les
gens qui tomberait malade pour être de
même reproché de l'avoir administrés
donc moi ne voulant prendre aucun risque
je t'appelle sa principe de précaution
mais je crois que la question du risque
zéro ça n'existe
quand on se prend le risque on le
déplace dire que quand on ne prend pas
de risques pour soi-même on en fait
courir aux autres donc on se protège les
dirigeants politiques se protéger
eux-mêmes et personnes droit rien leur
reprocher ils ont été impeccables ils
ont pris toutes les précautions
mais tous les gens qui ne sont pas
vaccinés qui n'ont pas été vaccinés
kidman se feront pas vacciner avec
astrazeneca cela on leur fait courir des
risques
seulement ça ce sont des risques qui ne
retombe sur personne autre que même au
nom de la précaution risque de faire des
morts nous dit paul pas eu kirya estime
qu'il faut rapidement recommencer à
vacciner avec astrazeneca
elle a en revanche où il n'y a aucun
recul dans le temps donc une fois de
plus c'est un pari basé sur un manque de
données scientifiques
le vaccin astrazeneca était centrale
dans la stratégie vaccinale du
gouvernement et sa suspension est un
gros coup dur pour emmanuel macron will
un autre côté c'est lui qui l'a décidé
il avaler parce qu'il a eu peur ils
n'avaient pas le choix ils aient peur
quand il a vu que les allemands le
faisait il s'est dit mais je me batte le
dernier à faire ça parce que si jamais
il y en avait 1 ne serait ce qu'un gars
qui a attrapé une thrombose et qui me
fasse un procès alors le faisant un peu
lui qui est responsable pénalement
m'enfin a collectivement à l'immersion
française omis de la santé au premier
ministre c'est à risque on veut pas
courir
et puis je vais vous dire l'élection
approche élections régionales mais avec
sur mon appartement talent élection
présidentielle donc ça va rendre le
poids de ce principe de précaution qui
ne protège à mon avis personne qui ne
fait que déplacer la cible et il y aura
peut-être plus de morts avec
l'application du principe de précaution
que 100 donc je crois que cet axe sont
tués beaucoup parlent approche
électorale qui va rentrer les hommes et
les femmes politiques de plus en plus
jeunes osent utiliser le terme prudent
un de plus en plus timide
quoi de plus en plus petits bras faisant
la comparaison ce qui s'est passé au
royaume uni incroyable le contraste les
anglais quand peut-être c'est dans le
tempérament national ne sorte
d'intrépidité britannique ils ont pris
depuis le début tous les risques et ils
ont d'abord commencé à financer des
projets de vaccins au risque de mettre
de l'argent à fonds perdus l'europe a
dit ah non nous on attendait d'eux sur
le financer résultat les vaccins ils ont
été fermés en angleterre ils ont
autorisé
ils ont mis en place le système de
vaccination quand les vaccins n'étaient
pas encore produit nous rien ils ont
autorisé des vaccins notamment
astrazeneca alors que nous on est en
train quand se gratter la tête en disant
à qui on peut l'admettre ils ont décidé
des cartes d'écarter les doses de
vaccins pour vacciner plus de monde à
tous les stades ils ont pris des risques
résultat un tiers de la pollution
britannique aujourd'hui vacciner et et
on voit les courbes de mortalité dur
d'urgence qui sont en train de baisser
c'est un mail où ils ont pris des
risques c'est à dire que boris johnson a
pris des risques peut-être que demain
s'il ya des accidents et on le dira
c'est d'autres mais c'est pas ça un
homme politique c'est pas ça la
responsabilité d'un homme d'état de
prendre des risques
gouverner c'est choisir comment ça peut
puisque justement la question se pose en
particulier sur l'île de france commence
à peser ces débats autour du confinement
dans la campagne pour les régionales
pascal alors pour l'instant en effet
l'acteur régional n'est pas un acteur de
premier plan quoique si l'on cherche
justement à voir ce qui a bougé depuis
mars en mars
tout était vue du centre national et de
l'appareil d'état
c'était la même chose de dunkerque à
marseille de brest à strasbourg
là où on voit bien qu'il y à une
approche régionale différencier même
parfois communal au niveau de
l'agglomération au niveau du département
c'est à mon avis un plus parce que la
france était un des rares pays d'europe
qui pratiquait en effet la même
politique du nord au sud et de l'est à
l'ouest
pour l'instant ça n'est pas très présent
dans une campagne des régionales qui met
un temps fou
voilà voilà qui ne démarre pas on
connaît pas encore tous les candidats la
région le département beaucoup de mal à
exister les français on les comprend on
la tête ont la tête vraiment vraiment à
autre chose ça change plutôt les
réactions des hommes et des femmes
politiques qui cherchent chacun se
positionner regarder ça se passe on va
peut-être voir ça dans une deuxième
partie justement qui est consacrée à ça
en attendant je redonne donc les la
question que du jour qui est sur le site
du figaro approuvez-vous le choix de
suspendre la vaccination par astrazeneca
est donc pour l'instant vous êtes une
petite majorité dire non à 50 57 % donc
c'est extrêmement partagées ne peut
continuer à voter
l'autre question qu'on possible celle là
l'est sur twitter avez vous observé donc
un changement dans la gestion de la
crise sanitaire par le gouvernement en
un an et un an après en tout cas on
pouvait se poser la question est ce
qu'on va aller vers les jours heureux
qui était souhaité par le président dans
l'une de ses nombreuses déclarations qui
a eu ce qui là qu'il a eu pendant la
tenue pendant le confinement voici en
tout cas ce qu en pense ce midi le maire
les républicains de cannes david lisnard
qui était l'invitée ici même deux frères
si on reprend un peu depuis un an ce qui
s'est passé on a l'impression
effectivement qu'à chaque étape
l'europe a été en retard de l'occident
et que la france a été en retard dans
l'europe est à la remarque de remorques
de l'europe c'était vrai sur les masques
sur les tests sur les lits de
réanimation c'est toujours aurait
d'ailleurs sur les lits de réanimation
malheureusement ça a été vrai mais
compris sur d'autres matériels les
thermomètres et c'est terminé
moi ya quelque chose qui m'avait
beaucoup frappée c'était lors du premier
confinement sur les obsèques et la
capacité d'aller voir les personnes en
ehpad
je pense qu'une civilisation qui ne rend
plus hommage à ses morts qui ne sait
plus non plus honorer et respecter ses
anciens décliner je crois que cette
crise
elle révèle un problème de leadership
français un problème d'exécutif présent
la république son gouvernement
mais le problème elle révèle un problème
structurants d'effondrement de
déclassement de notre civilisation et
notre pays il faut réagir faut vite
réagi faut vite avec c est ce que c'est
pas un peu sévère ce que dit david
lisnard
non ça me paraît plutôt frappé au coin
du bon sens non ce qui est vrai c'est
que si on met bout à bout la somme des
ratages qui sont pas toujours des
ratages politique et mon avis c'est plus
grave c'était un ratage administratifs
bureaucratiques donc c'est vraiment la
machine c'est l'état profond on parle
bosse à la mode de parler de l'état
profond mais qui est malade qui sait
plus agir ici on met bout à bout les
masques alors on les avait pas
renouveler on nous a expliqué qu'il
serait rien mais parce qu'on les hait
pas renouveler les tests qu'on savait
pas faire venir et puis conseil peut
utiliser effective et le traçage l
isolement des malades on en était
toujours incapable de faire quoi que ce
soit même l'application n'a pas su la
faire marcher la fallu des mois et des
mois pour qu'elle fonctionne
qu'est-ce que d'autres les les
les lits de réanimation n'a pas créé un
seul de plus et maintenant les vaccins
qu'on n'arrive pas à distribuer et on
n'avait même pas le moindre on sait pas
qui on les donne qui les donne qui les
distribue comme on les achemine on n'a
même pas là on n'avait pas prévu les
frigidaires les allemands ils ont acheté
dès qu'on a su que les vaccins se
conserver au moins 80 degrés ou quelque
chose comme ça ils ont fait une razzia
sur les originaires enfin un gars qui
est prévoyant avant même d'avoir une
bombe cherchaient tous cas sur le marché
nous non mais c'est d espèce de machine
administrative
on le savait c'est pas c'est pas né avec
le convie tout ça mais le coc weeds est
extraordinaire révélateur de plein de
choses dont ceux dont on parle d'isner
me semble-t-il cc7 cette lourdeur de la
machine bureaucratique industrie
française dont on l'a on se dit
maintenant c'est plus possible ça peut
pas durer comme ça une administration
qui est à ce point pléthorique qui coûte
à ce point cher aux finances publiques
quand on voit le prélèvement obligatoire
quand on voit là le taux de dépenses
publiques pour finalement ne pas être
capable d'administrer des vaccins à des
gens c'est pas non plus sorcier c2c de
l'intendance de gaulle c'est nathan
suivra mais en france on a prévenu en
attendant ça compte pas on s'en fiche
mais non la tendance est très important
que comme on fait pas de guerre 101
tendance qu'est ce que ça veut dire et
donc on va nous la tendance fit plus est
ce que c'est pas pour reprendre
également parce que le révélateur de il
ya en tout cas sa perception dans
l'opinion soit d'avoir votre avis d'un
dec la même oui bien sûr si vous voulez
la france a eu pendant très longtemps
une image très positive de son
administration on était très bien malgré
moi je vous coupe en effet ici même à
votre place il ya un an au tout début de
la crise des intérêts des intérêts des
invités consistera pas que dit on a un
système de santé que le frob le monde
entier nous on voit là on nous envie
notre système de santé notre système
d'éducation nous envieraient tous ont la
france serait en effet un centre où on
accumulait les bijoux de famille non le
problème c'est que les bijoux de famille
ont beaucoup ternie qui nous envient
aujourd'hui par exemple notre système
universitaire je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y
en a énormément qui nous envient
aujourd'hui notre système de santé
public après les ratés qu alexis brézet
rappelait tout même sur la longue
période sur un an parce qu'il suffit pas
d'avoir des principes vertueux il faut
avoir des pratiques solides pour
être en oeuvre ces principes vertueux et
là on a l'impression tout de même que
l'administration n'a pas été à la
hauteur
qu'est ce qu'elle a fait elle s'est
retournée un peu dans la panique on le
voyait les ars parmi les fameuses
agences régionales de santé sa foire est
un peu alors on se retournait vers en
dernier recours vers la fhp on a fait de
la fédération de l'hospitalisation
privée c'est-à-dire les acteurs privés
qui proposait depuis des semaines et des
semaines ses services sans avoir
beaucoup d' écoute on s'est retourné
vers les régions s'est retourné vers les
départements s'est retourné vers les
communes
voyez tout d'un coup ça a donné l'idée
que l'état à la française
eh bien ça n'était pas vraiment une
réussite que cet état obèse cher 1
n'était pas efficace parce qu'ils
seraient obèses et cher et efficace
on se dirait au fond pourquoi pas on en
a pour notre argent
on en a pour notre argent mais la voyez
il ya le sentiment que ya cette demande
d'état en france parce qu'on se fait pas
du jour au lendemain
c'est une demande d'états qui qui est là
depuis des décennies même parfois des
siècles mais il se pose une question il
ya une réelle interrogation aujourd'hui
sur l'efficacité de l'action publique et
là je ne suis pas sûr que ceux qui ont
préconisé une montée en puissance de la
puissance publique s'en sortent sans
avoir des réponses convaincantes à mais
est ce que tout ça c'est efficace
est-ce que mais est-ce que c'est pas
aussi le révélateur justement de notre
grande place delà de cette puissance de
cette administration et le politique qui
a été étouffée qui s'est hissé dans un
même un premier temps un petit peu rangé
derrière l'école et les conseils
scientifiques pour justifier de ses
décisions et que janvier a marqué un
retour qui était un retour du politique
le politique d'abord idée d'abord il est
trés désarmés face à des phénomènes qui
comprend pas connaît pas et c'est vrai
quelques choses d'abord voudra
prétendent un peu naturel de se
retourner vers les gens qui sont censés
savoir qui sont les administrations
compétentes notamment la conversion de
la santé si on a des ars si on a des
directions de la santé si on a des ils
sont censés normand conseiller le
gouvernement le gouvernant ça peut pas
non plus tomber tout droit du ciel
il va donc c'est un peu normal de se
tourner vers ça après se pose la
question de la capacité du mal à se
faire obéir
parce que prendre des décisions c'est
une chose mais si ensuite derrière ça
suit pas
combien de fois on nous a fait le coup à
emmanuel macron n'est pas content et
même un qu'on a dit ça ne peut plus
durer comme ça on va il tape du poing
sur la table
combien de nous-mêmes offriront des
masques on a tapé du poing sur la table
il a dit que les vaccins ça n'allait pas
que les ceux ci ça n'allait pas que des
tests sana les packs so what
mais c'est pas de sa fin c'est pas de sa
faute il est responsable donc c'est de
sa faute mais c'est qu'il ya un moment
si l'administration suis passé qu'il
imprime dans l'administration et donc je
pense que la prochaine campagne
présidentielle stas c'est un thème qui
avait un peu disparu du discours public
alors c'est peut-être raison c'est
d'être qui a trop d'état trop
d'administration que du coup elle répond
plus qu'elle est obèse
on peut discuter mais en tout cas la
question de l'efficacité est une
question désormais ne peut plus ne peut
pas ne pas être posée elle va se poser à
la présidence et surtout quand vous
inscrire et tout ça dans une rhétorique
guerrière on avait le discours d'il ya
un an
la guerre attendait alors la guerre on
s'attend à des résultats au satan
défaire des protections efficaces et là
on a l'impression qu'ils un chef de
guerre qui en est fait comme bon à part
pour l art comme celle de la honte réuni
le conseil de défense il ya une
atmosphère tout à fait martial pendant
la pression du côté des cantinières ça
ne suit plus du côté de ceux qui
appellent le matériel et les munitions
ça suit mal donc au bout d'un moment
c'est quoi c'est la panique quoi à la
fin on dit aux gens
bon bah pendant la guerre vous on a
trouvé la solution vous allez vous
mettre aux abris
parce que la sanction de cette la
capacité administrative et
bureaucratique c'est que on va dire que
là c'est le confinement et puisqu'on n'y
arrive pas à voir les masques les tests
le
tracez isoler les lits les vaccins on
vous enferme chez vous mais c'est donc
on envers les populations civiles pour
les mettre à l'abri
c'est comme le degré zéro de
l'efficacité dans un état neuf ans et
être moderne agile il faut peut-être en
venir là je dis pas que tout confinement
est par nature absurdes et inutiles etc
mais l'utiliser comme une arme
systématique parce qu'on sait pas faire
autre chose et que le reste marche pas
c'est que c'est quand même qui est un
problème
est-ce que vous qui avez travaillé sur
le populisme justement tout ce qu'on a
vécu depuis un an est de nature à faire
monter le populisme oui parce que si
vous voulez quand la france va mal ce
que je dis depuis très longtemps ça et
bien les partis populistes se porte bien
général parce que ce sont des forces
politiques qui très souvent dénonce
rejette c'est une politisation qu'on
appelle négative c'est le yaka faudrait
quoi bon quand ils sont au pouvoir on
s'aperçoit que l'efficacité public des
populistes n'est pas majeur
il suffit de se souvenir de trump et de
ses premières réactions face à la cage
vide ou de bol sonar au brésil enfants
n'a pas l'impression en effet que ce
soit des gens plus efficace plus
efficaces que d'autres
donc ça nourrit cette protestation
populiste surtout dans un pays la france
où il ya beaucoup d'attentes par rapport
à l'action publique et donc quand on est
déçu par l'efficacité la pertinence de
cette action publique
ça nourrit des réactions de colère de
ressentiment énorme sur le plan social
on a eu les gilet jaune
on peut avoir sur le plan politique
voyez un peu un équivalent et gilet
jaune
voilà cependant on n'a pas vu quand même
une opposition très très très forte
enfin très présente dans ce nom c'est de
la même façon que le gilet jaune se sont
fait en dehors de tout parti politique
quand même si les mélenchonistes à la
façon mis dessus pour essayer de
récupérer le bébé
ce sont des mouvements qui excède
absolument les parties de l'est ces
mouvements de colère dehors de peur qu
est-ce qui sait comme un nom de peur
d'inquiétude d'angoise et le risque
grand qu'à l'issue de cette année une
espèce d'explosion quand on a eu peur
souvent non on en veut aux gens qui ont
fait on en vend on envie aux autres de
sa propre peur et donc
les difficultés économiques qui vont
être évidente parce que on a beau mettre
des cautères sur une jambe de bois tout
à fait utile d'ailleurs de économique il
ya un moment où il va falloir passer à
la caisse économique ça va être très
très lourd donc on va se retrouver en
sortie de crise avec des gens qui ont
été tendus et nerveux inquiets des prix
mais frustrés dans des conditions
économiques objectivement difficile et
qui vont pas s'arranger et qui en plus
haut sur ma faisant son ordi mais les
gars qui nous valent ils sont quand même
pas fort alors on dit pas qu'ils ont
tous mais enfin on sait pas trop ce
qu'on aurait fait mais ce qu'on sait
c'est que lorsqu'ils ont fait ils n'ont
pas bien fait donc c'est vrai qu'on peut
évidemment prédire l'avenir mais enfin
on peut imaginer qu'en tout cas les
conditions de deux des espèces de
d'ébullition social très brutal est-ce
que l'apparition de nouveaux varions
pourrait avoir un impact sur le
comportement de l'opinion ah oui parce
que on a l'impression que d'abord le
danger fait retour mais pas simplement
sous une forme sous plusieurs formes
donc là ça peut accentuer beaucoup les
peurs d'autre part on sait que certains
variants comme le varié en sud africains
ont un taux de mortalité nettement
supérieur aux autres
donc la peur que pour soi même pour les
siens en effet cela se traduise à la fin
des fins par des issues extrêmement
négative
donc tout ça est anxiogène en rajoute
sur le pessimisme et sur le fait que les
français voient de moins en moins
comment ils vont en sortir parce qu'on
leur a dit alors attention aux effets
d'annoncé là comme ailleurs on leur a
dit tout de même à la fin de l'été ça
sera réglé ça sera réglé fin août à peu
près tout le monde aura enfin tous les
gens mule qui doivent être vaccinés
auront été vaccinés
voyez comme c'est parti mais c'est
intenable
cette échéance donc il y aura forcément
une déception
il faudra pour ceux qui ont annoncé cela
j'allais dire passer à la caisse
1 et forcément il y aura des déceptions
à feuilles administratif français
auxquels on ajoute la lourdeur
européenne beau résultat ce que nous dit
cette internaute sur le site du figaro
oui c'est vrai que là ce prêt européen
l'europe a aussi sa part de
responsabilité cette europe qui devait
protéger ce qu'ont les gens tentent de
l'europe on est plus nombreux on se
protège on est plus fort et c'est vrai
que l arast telle affaire et notamment
la sphère des vaccins tels qu'on a voulu
faire des économies de bouts de
chandelles on à mégoter
on se dit on veut être où on va on va
creuser sur les tarifs et pendant que
les autres acheter acheter acheter
nous on négociait on attendait pour voir
si les prix elle n'est pas blessée bon
résultat c'est que maintenant on en a
pas de vaccin pour garder ce que la
petite démocratie mais très agile
israélienne a fait et ils n'ont pas
mégoté sur les prix d'un voilà ils ont
maintenant leur population avec c'est ce
qu'ont fait les anglais et les anglais
en europe les deux pays qui s'en tire le
mieux cet epic cependant lieu c'est
l'esrb les anglais il faut quand même
voir qu'en terme de vaccins ont fait
moins bien que maroc
une question qui peut se poser sur
l'efficacité de notre système et de
l'union européenne en la matière après
un an de vie plus personne ne doit nous
envier c'est entre le casque 17
internautes nicole qu'on salue avez vous
observé un changement dans la gestion de
la crise sanitaire par le gouvernement
en un an c'est la question qu'on vous
posez sur twitter et à vous répondez
vous avez été nombreux à voter vous
répondez non à 68%
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis
désolé on n'a pas été très très
optimiste dans tous les cas on essayait
de voir quelle était la situation quand
même dire au général s'élève à la lexus
et les vaccins c'est pour ça qu'il faut
que les gouvernants met tout en oeuvre
et que les citoyens c'est tout le reste
d'ailleurs y a tout même des boudins ce
paysage un peu triste des portes
éventuellement d'espoir on verra aussi
comment les autorités sanitaires
nationales et européennes vont se
prononcer sur les vaccins qui viennent
d'ailleurs un vaccin russe olga que ça
chinois etc
on verra c'est ce qu'on va guetter
maintenant dans les prochains jours les
prochaines semaines merci beaucoup de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve demain
même heure même endroit avec guillaume
roquette a très vite sur fear alive
[Musique]